hmm there could be like an in-between
move like just the night getting out of
the way and then before you know it
there's Queen coming out to kill my
night so I could get this bish up with
my night right now or or I could run
forward with f4 Wow okay I have to be
very cautious here because after f4
there is Bishop here and if I really am
insisting on getting that Bishop I'm
needing to play h6 and then g5 but I'm
definitely compromising my king position
and moves like Queen here I could end up
in what's very close to looking like a
fool's mate
so f4 Bishop here h6 is their way to get
to this square I think there might be
night here g5 the bishop is trapped if
Knight g6 I get out of the way
if pawn push I run away with my knight
and then I have the bishop at the end of
it I'm gonna actually try it I hope I
think it's working let's give it a go
I've invested a ton of time this has
only moved for spent half half my
allotted time but hopefully this pays
off here really tried to make those
accurate moves early on and now
hopefully this is working out
falou the calculations I ran here are
working where are they they're not
working are they there's there's
something as simple as a pawn move to g5
or g4 isn't there there's a month
there's a pawn move right here that I
overlooked is my opponent listening if
you're listening don't do g4 do
something else
don't digi for anything here like play
8/3 that's a good one a three or a four
a three actually a three with rook a to
to follow oh I totally missed that move
Oh trouble I'm in trouble and this is a
winning move I'm beat
I got a run for the hills oh I'm a dead
man I'm a dead duck dead duck right here
Oh light squares I was just seeing the
Queen coming out in this direction mate
in one thread right here I got a pack up
and run pack up and run but it's very
very scary over here very very scary mmm
very very scary okay so what a wonderful
example of how not to play okay but wait
there's still something to take away
from this because look at the the mental
block I had right there I was fixated
okay I have no choice but to run so you
better run and I can't even go clear
because it's just chopped I don't even
get my piece back I please okay let's go
King you know you want to run to c7 I
need time burners time burners that's
all I got come be with me o'clock my
king is running for the hills
Oh run for the hills run King you just
have to take off fly run like the wind
blows no let's go my king is tucked in
he's nice and cozy right here on c7 for
the time being
what's this guy gonna do nothing soon
that's a sad story he's a sad story
right here this guy okay
oh man
okay let's hit the Queen chipping away
at the time I'm chipping away my dark
square Bishop is gonna spring to life
I'm on the Queen huh is the Queen gonna
get trapped I think I want to just trade
Queens ha ha ha even though I'm down
material I just want to get the lady out
of here you need to go the woman needs
to get out of here get out of here oh
they're having none of that okay maybe I
could trade over here please let's just
straight I think by force the Queens
have to come off I'm on the night I'm
still on the night Oh less than two
minutes I'm playing down a piece and a
pun right all righty here we go here we
go here we go I just dropped another
part they could have chopped this guy up
okay what's the plan
get this pawn up that's the big plan 145
144 Queen to d3
you idiot you could there's a couple
different ways the Queen could get on
the diagonal note to self Queen t3 it
definitely did feel a little fuzzy but I
was just completely overlooking that wow
wow maybe the biggest note I could be
making myself is don't play the Dutch
you're a fool when you play the Dutch
don't be a fool don't play the Dutch
easy six or not at a time tick tick tick
tick tick
pompous my bishops ready to rumble
he's rumbling pawn push here
pawn push here my opponent completely
outplayed me in the opening oh there
wasn't an a good way to take advantage
of that okay get out of there Knight I
could have been taking this pawn okay
I'm getting some material back got some
pieces okay I got some pawns that could
run four touchdowns looking to run four
touchdowns here bishop here grab a pond
right here this is a glue if you didn't
know this this is the this is the glue
right here my bishop he's gluing
everything together he's making things
stick he's providing the coordination in
other words so let's control this I
don't want this night getting excited
about coming here what's happening with
that okay I'm actually back on time and
I have actually a couple pawns now to
play with here rook here
bishop here there's no time though
there's no time and this pawn is excited
to be running fast pawn push leading to
a fork actually this is winning this is
now all of a sudden winning okay with
check
now take and no time to figure it out oh
that was probably a mouse let Bishop
here I'm assuming that's what was meant
oh good game by you not by me let me see
that was a tear you capitalized on my
foolish play right there my opponent is
saying good game back to me and that
they ran out of time yes let's have a
look at it oh and a fantastic example of
how not to play right here this you have
to believe me when I say it this right
here it was I was cringing again I was
fearful of the Queen I was just uh uh
just focused on Queen coming up to age
five plus she go somewhere else look at
g6 that is a juicy juicy square King f7
I get absolutely crushed nightly five
right King here Knight check King here I
got a runaway by night there's at least
a perpetual right there at least I don't
know I felt it was best to just take a
hike with my king towards the Queen side
uh did he have to run fast so what's the
what's the plan here let's just take it
from here even though black is beat
what's the winning method what would you
do here I think geez three is a good
move good move bishops out if I take
then the rook springs to life I don't
have this move because it spin this pawn
is pinned it's powerless now what about
now
what about just take I mean here there
here's a more solid approach check this
out how about you just chop my night
kill them and then and then just plant
your pawns on dark squares pawn here
Bishop here queenside castle so maybe
don't even go a Forbes it's probably
just not even needed just just stay
really solid with your structure you're
up upon and a piece right so something
like just taking my knight out if you
really wanted to and then submit your
punched pawns on dark squares it's
working well it's coordinated well with
your light square bishop and go from
there
I know there's definitely time
constraints on this and you know have
all day but even right here actually I'm
dropping another bomb chop chop chop
chop chop again my Kings running scared
so this was another opportunity to go up
not up not only be up a minor piece and
a pawn but minor piece and two pawns
right take take take a couple times here
and I'm dead okay ah let me close oh wow
scary time here with the Dutch defense
if I've seen better days in the Dutch
defence